es una de las ciudades más afectadas en
Turquía por este terremoto que ocurrió
hace algo más de dos días la madrugada
del domingo al lunes y ahora mismo nos
encontramos en uno de los campos
improvisados creados por las por los
servicios de emergencia turcos para
intentar hospedar temporalmente a las
personas que o han perdido sus casas o
tienen miedo de volver a ellas porque
han sido dañadas o tienen problemas
estructurales después de este terremoto
en este campo hay nos explican los
servicios de seguridad y de apoyo a las
víctimas cerca de un par o tres de miles
de personas en estos Campos en esas
tiendas improvisadas que sin embargo en
su interior tienen unas condiciones
relativamente dignas explican los ciclos
que existan ahora temporalmente evitando
que reciben comida caliente por parte de
la media luna roja y que por las noches
Aunque hay rudio ruido y hace mucho frío
porque aquí las temperaturas bajan a
varios grados bajo cero es mejor esto
que vivir eosar durmiendo en la calle
que hay muchas personas tanto en esa
ciudad como en otras más dañadas que
tienen que hacerlo estamos hablando de
otras ciudades como gantep o ataque que
son las más afectadas con más muertos
esas ciudades han desaparecido
completamente del mapa Osmani aún sigue
en pie en algunos lugares sin embargo la
gente que no puede escapar de esa ciudad
muchos lo están haciendo los que pueden
los que no terminan en sitios y en
Campos como este